hey hey how'd the run go
oh pretty good I finished that's great
why is that great because they
accomplished something
what was your mild time about seven I
could beat that on a skateboard well
that has wheels yeah well my feet don't
and I could still crush that time really
Dwight not faster you let's just put it
this way last weekend
I outran a black pepper snake really I
am fast to give you a reference point
I'm somewhere between a snake and a
mongoose and a panther man what is
shaking Toby so long oh I'll just time
him later and you'll compare the times
yeah are you ready no am I being mean to
Dwight I don't know I did just make him
run around the building and I have no
intention of timing him
this isn't even a stopwatch it's a
digital thermometer he does make my life
harder sometimes and on purpose like he
tried to put meters on the bathroom
stalls as a way of bringing in more
money for the company hey three more
laps to go you gotta pick it up you're
gonna beat Toby I should probably get
back to work
[Music]
[Laughter]
seriously okay okay yes I have a wig for
every single person in the office you
never know when you're gonna need to
bear a passing resemblance to someone I
just want it to stop here we go
college Roadshow gotta bring our a-game
what is the most inspiring thing I ever
said to you don't be an idiot
changed my life whenever I'm about to do
something I think would an idiot do that
and if they would I do not do that thing
oh man is that a prism duro sport you've
seen one of these yeah they're like an
iPod only they're better because they're
chunkier and more solid Roy gave it to
me for Christmas I'm trying to figure
out how to put songs on it oh no no no
don't go there
I know this Russian website you can
download songs for two cents apiece
really yeah I'll write down the address
for you only the only thing is is that
all the songs are in Russian kidding why
would the AL beat okay see you later Pan
yeah me a cup of coffee me too or do you
also have a monopoly on thirst okay guys
it didn't work out for any of us so
we're still on the same team let me get
these no let him get his own he's got
sir Q's money you know your partner's
got a lot of attitude but I like that
how long you guys been dating Jim
couldn't land me in a thousand years but
you're saying there's a chance
shut up Cumberland Mills and how did you
get my resume oh no no I'm very
flattered don't get me wrong I'm just
not sure that it's my official resume or
if it's something that maybe a satisfied
customer posted online what does it say
under martial arts training oh okay I'm
gonna have to supplement that could I
have your fax number would I ever leave
this company look I'm all about loyalty
in fact I feel like part of what I'm
gonna be paid for here is my loyalty but
if there were somewhere else that valued
that loyalty more highly I'm going
wherever they value loyalty the most on
or off Oh what is on your face is that a
disguise
clown paint ID badges are long overdue
security in this office park is a joke
last year I came to work with my spud
gun in a duffel bag I set up my desk all
day with a rifle that shoots potatoes at
60 pounds per square inch can you
imagine if I was deranged
you are going to do everything humanly
possible to ensure that this never
happens again
well it doesn't help because it already
happened to the watermark it's a
one-time thing
I don't care it was disgusting it a
cartoon characters having sex then I
point out that the sex appeared to be
consensual both animals were smiling
okay I grew up on a farm I have seen
animals having sex in every position
imaginable go down chicken chicken on
goat a couple of chickens doing a goat a
couple of pigs watching whoever drew
this got it exactly right
what did I do
I did my job I slashed benefits to the
bone I saved this company money
was I too harsh maybe I don't believe in
coddling people and the wild there is no
health care in the wild health care is
how I hurt my leg
I can't run a lion eats me and I'm dead
well I'm not dead I'm the lion you're
dead just hit me you'll see I can't cuz
I just got a manicure so oh cool here I
queer I that's a good show important
show go ahead do it
just some do I plunge you Yoshi well
that would be kind of worthless because
I know a ton of fourteen-year-old girls
again kick is if you know a ton of
fourteen-year-old girls what belt are
they look Dwight is a wuss when we
rented Armageddon no ride at the end of
it Michael I told you that was because
it was New Year's Eve and it started to
snow at exactly midnight punt you oh
okay here we go
come on oh did I want to harm Michael
the one man I've been hired to protect
no I did not okay all right thank you I
come from a long line of fighters my
maternal grandfather was the toughest
guy I ever knew World War two veteran
killed 20 men then spent the rest of the
war in an allied prison camp
my father battled blood pressure and
obesity all his life different kind of
fight as a volunteer sheriff's deputy
I've been doing surveillance for years
one time I suspected an ex-girlfriend of
mine of cheating on me
so I tailed her for six nights straight
turns out she was with a couple of guys
actually so mystery solved let's go over
some of these symptoms of marijuana use
shall we you tell me who this sounds
like slow-moving inattentive dull
constantly snacking shows a lack of
motivation
hey I like the people I work with
generally with four exceptions but
someone committed a crime and I did not
become a Lackawanna County volunteer
sheriff's deputy to make friends and by
the way I haven't okay I will only need
two things a roll of duct tape and a
knife I'm on it okay 30 minutes relax
please come back save the receipts Hey
what hey wait wait I keep various
weaponry strategically placed around the
office
I saved Jim's life with a can of pepper
spray
I had velcroed under my desk people say
oh it's dangerous to keep weapons in the
home or the workplace well I say it's
better to be hurt by someone you know
accidentally than by a stranger on
purpose
what you're saying is extremely
misogynistic yes thank you that was not
necessary but I appreciated it and
proves my point
women can do anything I'm saying that
you're being sexist
no I'm being misogynistic that is insane
I'm not being sexist that's not
sustainable
yes when I got my hair cut chart you
asked me if I was a lesbian because wow
that was one possible explanation as to
why you got that haircut and when we get
mad you always ask us to form in our
periods I have to know whether you're
serious or not I wish I could men
straight if I could men straight I
wouldn't have to deal with idiotic
calendars anymore I'll just be able to
count down from my previous cycle plus I
see more in tune with the tides
you